hallo leute wir sprechen heute über ein
thema das viele menschen nicht verstehen
nämlich dass pfandflaschen system in
deutschland
in deutschland zahlt man für viele
flaschen dosen oder gläser fand das
heißt im supermarkt zahlt ist für so
etwas ein bisschen mehr und die idee ist
dass ihr dieses geld zurückbekommt wenn
ihr diese flasche in den supermarkt
zurück bringt und damit soll man helfen
dass man die flaschen und die dosen
schneller oder besser recyceln kann aber
das system ist auch ein bisschen
kompliziert denn es gibt
unterschiedliche fand preise und es gibt
nicht auf allen flaschen fand und ja das
ist tatsächlich kompliziert sogar für
deutsche
trotzdem möchten wir euch das heute
erklären denn wir kennen sogar ausländer
die in deutschland leben und nach jahren
in deutschland ihre pfandflaschen immer
noch in den müll werfen
das muss nicht sein denn so kompliziert
ist es auch nicht und wir versuchen es
heute mal zu erklären die erste frage
die wir heute beantworten ist welche
flaschen kann ich überhaupt
zurückbringen
janus und ich versuchen das jetzt mal zu
klären kann ich für diese flasche main
fand zurück bekommt ja diese flasche
kann man zurück bringen und hier steht
das auch drauf hier steht pfandflasche
15 cent pfand segelt und kann ich für
diese schöne flasche auch mein fand
zudem bringt sehr gute frage jannis das
ist eine flasche gin für solche flaschen
bekommt man kein pfand und ich weiß
nicht warum ich dachte immer die regel
ist das etwas wie glasflaschen eine
glasflasche ist aber es gibt ja auch
glasflaschen die man zurückbringen kann
aber schnapsflaschen kann man nie zurück
bringen ja weil es geht mehr um das
recycling es geht darum mir darum dass
diese flaschen quasi oder diese flaschen
noch mal benutzt werden können die
bierflasche wird noch mal benutzt die
den flasche mich ja warum in diesem
flasche kann man auch noch mal sinnvoll
diese bierflasche hingegen eine
herkömmliche flasche wird ja so wie alle
bierflaschen eigentlich alle
bierflaschen kann man zurückbringen in
deutschland man bekommt acht cent dafür
was ist mit dieser flasche diese flasche
kommt aus österreich
deshalb hat sie keinen fand denn wir
haben sie nicht in deutschland gekauft
das ist auch wichtig flaschen die im
ausland gekauft wurden haben natürlich
keinen fand in deutschland und viele
geschäfte zum beispiel türkische im
messe benutzen flaschen aus dem ausland
nahm mit die kunden kein fan zahlen
müssen also das seht ihr manchmal auch
in so kleinen läden wo man döner kauft
oder pommes kauft gibt es ganz auf dosen
und kleine flaschen ohne fand ok weiter
geht's mit dieser hübschen flasche das
ist leider auch eine schnapsflasche kein
pfand
ok dann geht's weiter
was ist mit dieser standard flasche
diese flasche hat ein ganz typisches
fand symbol das seht ihr hier vorne
dieses symbol heißt wir können die
flasche in den supermarkt zurückbringen
darauf könnt ihr 18 wenn ihr eine
flasche sieht nicht alle pfandflaschen
haben das symbol aber alle flaschen
mitteln symbol kann man zurückbringen
ok und unser letztes beispiel ist diese
flasche
das ist eine saft flasche und wie viele
saftflaschen hat sie keinen fand und
fragt uns bitte nicht warum wir
verstehen das system auch nicht denn
eine eine saftflaschen könnte man
theoretisch auch noch einmal benutzen
genauso wie eine wasserflasche
aber es gibt kein fand vielleicht weiß
das jemand von euch schreibt uns mal
einen kommentar warum zahlt man für
wasserflaschen fand und für saftflaschen
keinen fand unsere zweite frage ist wie
viel pfand bekomme ich für welche
flasche
es gibt unterschiedliche preise zwischen
18 und 50 cent tatsächlich unser erstes
beispiel ist eine typische bierflasche
genau von diesen bierflaschen muss man
sehr viel bier trinken um viel geld zu
bekommen denn sie haben wenig fand ein
alle bierflaschen haben acht cent pfand
oder ich glaube alle glasflaschen
allgemein 18
ok nächstes beispiel diese
plastikflaschen haben zwischen 15 und 25
cent pfand
ich glaube auf diese flasche steht 15
cent diese flasche hat auch 15 cent
denke ich und es gibt manche flaschen
auch mit 25 cent und dosen sie haben
auch 25 sind also fast alles was ihr
kauft hat 8 15 oder 25 sind angeblich
gibt es auch flaschen oder gläser mit 50
cent
die habe ich noch nie in meinem leben
gesehen
die dritte frage ist wie bekomme ich
mein geld zurück
schritt eins ist alle flaschen im haus
finden und einpacken
jetzt bringen wir die pfandflaschen zum
supermarkt
dieses geräusch wisst ihr jemand hat
viel bier getrunken werden
jetzt sind hier im supermarkt und
streckt seine flaschen in den
pfandautomaten in jedem sommer in
deutschland gibt es so eine ganz alte
mann jetzt drückt ja nicht auf den
grünen knopf und bekommt seinen bon
er hat 48 cent verdient für 64 flaschen
damit kann janus jetzt einkaufen gehen
das war unser video überhand flaschen in
deutschland wenn ihr noch fragen habt
dann schreibt uns unbedingt einen
kommentar und wenn ihr antworten habt zu
unseren fragen dann schreibt uns auch
einen kommentar wir gehen jetzt
einkaufen mit 48 cent und wir freuen uns
wenn die sie gern unterstützt
dann werdet doch einfach ein patch in
das könnt ihr hier machen und ihr könnt
ihr sie german abonnieren
und zwar da müssen tiefer und dann
bekommt ihr immer nachrichten
benachrichtigungen über neue videos und
bis bald